The Trump campaign and right wing media have
been falling all over themselves over the last 24
hours to promote a story by The New York Post, a
supposed game changing, earth shattering bombshell
about Joe Biden. And the entire story may be fake.
At minimum, it is not what we would call reputable
reporting. And I've gone back and forth over the
last 12 hours about whether to talk about this
today. I've received enough e-mails about this
that I do want to discuss it at least briefly.
So I want to give you the simplest explanation of
the story as it is alleged. First, then we'll talk
about what we actually know to be true and whether
this story matters. So the story is as follows.
Yesterday, The New York Post publishes an article
based on suppose it emails reportedly obtained
from a laptop that Joe Biden's son, Hunter
Biden, had allegedly left at a computer repair
shop in Delaware in April of twenty nineteen.
So already we have a lot of if ands and buts,
speculation and unproven assertions. The gist of
the supposed emails is that Hunter Biden arranged
for a top Ukrainian energy executive to meet with
Joe Biden, who at the time was the vice president.
Supposedly Boris PSMA adviser Vadim Pisarski
wrote an email to Hunter Biden. And in the email,
Pisarski says to Hunter Biden, Thank you for
inviting me to DC and giving an opportunity to
meet your father and spend some time together. So
instantly the Trump campaign and the right have
been going crazy saying, si, si, Joe Biden lied.
This was a conflict of interest. Hunter Biden was
influence peddling while he was on the board of
this Ukrainian energy company, Berrys WMA. Biden
lied. It's all true. Now, if the story is true
exactly as described, it would be a problem for
Joe Biden, at least to some degree. Although Trump
and his family have done what Joe Biden is accused
of doing a hundred times over. The Trump is don't
care. There have been no repercussions. But yes,
if this story is true, it would lead to having to
answer some questions, OK? But the thing is that
now more serious journalistic entities have looked
at the story. The story may not even be true. The
first question is what? This laptop, a laptop was
supposedly left 18 months ago in a repair shop
and the repair shop owner copied the hard drive
and has now turned it over to Rudy Giuliani and
others. It's already very weird. The emails that
are in the story aren't actual screenshots of
emails. There is no header in. So there is no
metadata. It's a screenshot of a PDAF. It's a
screenshot PDAF. It could be from a real email.
It could be totally fake. We don't know. Next,
even if the email that is purported to be an
e-mail to Hunter Biden is a real email to Hunter
Biden, it's not clear if the email refers to
something that happened or to something that
the Russian executive is hoping happens, he says
in the email. Thank you for inviting me to D.C..
That could be. Thank you for something that took
place or something that maybe could take place.
Thank you for giving me an opportunity to meet
your father. Unclear if that actually took place.
And we'll get to that next. Even if it is what it
purports to be, there is no indication that Hunter
Biden ever replied to the email. And the story
doesn't even allege that Hunter Biden replied.
And officials who work for Joe Biden say no such
meeting actually took place. Now, in the meantime,
the Biden campaign has said it's conceivable that
at some event, Biden might have shaken hands with
this Ukrainian executive along with dozens or
hundreds of other people. This is a defense
Donald Trump often uses. Donald Trump will often
claim he doesn't know somebody. Pictures come
out of Trump hugging the guy. And then Trump says,
listen, I take he'd say they've actually said,
I've taken millions of pictures like that. And the
Trump ists are satisfied with that explanation.
So they conceivably should be satisfied
with that same explanation here,
if indeed it is the explanation. And then the
last reason to be skeptical of all of this
is that Rudy Giuliani appears to be
behind all of it. Donald Trump's,
I guess, still lawyer and henchmen. And I would
be at this point looking at anything that comes
from Rudy Giuliani with skeptical eyes. In
the end, I think this changes nothing about
the election. There are rumors that much more
on Hunter Biden is coming. If that happens,
then we will have to examine it and reevaluate
whether it does anything in terms of the election.
This story from The New York Post, I think
does nothing in terms of the election.
And if this is the October surprise, it
really is a very weak October surprise. If
you disagree with me, let me know.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman,